on a deux vies et la deuxième débute
lorsque l'on
perçoit que
seul bonjour je m'appelle lionel je
travaille dans une petite entreprise et
j'ai fondé une association age 2 vie en
neige une seule et vous vous en avez
combien alors quelle que soit la réponse
à la question est pour ma part une chose
est sûre je ne suis pas un héros
ah non ça c'est sûr un héros ça meurt à
la fin c'est nul moi je suis plutôt
enfin tenez regardez comme ça se passe
mal pour les héros vercingétorix mort
sitting bull mort jean moulin luther
king gandhi tous morts
franchement ça donne pas envie non moi
je suis plutôt comme toutes celles et
tous ceux qui sont nés dans les années
70 80
est ce que vous vous souvenez de cette
époque je me lance alors ça faisait papa
papa papa papa nous sommes voyez là et
puis il y avait aussi capitaine flam tu
n'es pas non elle y avait également
albert en alberta
bon je sais pas si vous avez compris
mais en tout cas mesdames et messieurs
comme toutes celles et tous ceux de ma
génération je suis ce qu'on appelle
humblement un super héros est un super
héros ne meurent jamais c'est beaucoup
mieux
alors nous les super héros
on nous appelle toujours quand rien ne
va plus à l'est au goldorak
oui j'écoute la faut venir on a un
problème
1 bougez pas j'arrive goldorak go et les
problèmes en ce moment c'est pas ce qui
manque
et encore si on avait que celui la
pollution galopante de l'eau de l'air
des sols dérèglement climatique en mode
exponentielle sixième extinction de
masse des espèces faune flore
le tableau est pas terrible alors c'est
normal qu'on nous appelle nous les les
super héros pour sauver la terre on est
les seuls à être capable de le faire
bah oui souvenez-vous dans dans chacun
des épisodes
à la fin on sauve les hommes les femmes
les enfants les animaux les forêts les
lacs les rivières bref on sauve tout et
tout le monde sait ce qui me plaît moins
quand j'étais petit garçon toute ma
jeunesse a été bercée par les aventures
de ses supérieurs en dessin animé
je les regardais dans les troncs td puis
après j'ai essayé d'aller les imiter
dans ma chambre pour après me produire
dans la cour de récré et à mon avis
comme beaucoup d'entre vous ici ou
devant vos écrans
tenez j'ai appris une chose dernièrement
tous les héros des mangas japonais dont
je viens de vous parler dans leur grande
majorité avait une trentaine d'années
quand ils les ont écrits ça veut dire
qu'ils sont les enfants de nagasaki et
d'hiroshima
ils ont connu le chaos ils ont connu les
drames ils ont vécu un monde qui
s'écroule
ils ont grandi dans un pays traumatisé
par le cataclysme nucléaire et ce qu'ils
portent en eux transpire dans chacun de
leurs épisodes explosion en forme de
champignon nucléaire déportation de
population vers d'autres planètes et ma
génération à travers ses aventures en
garde les stigmates sans doute
sommes-nous un petit peu plus sensibles
ouais en 2021 la situation plutôt simple
un tout le monde l'a compris la planète
est en danger face aux critiques il et
nous avec
bon et je crois qu'un seul super héros
ne suffirait pas pour la sauver c'est
donc la raison pour laquelle est bien
j'ai fondé odyssée les trois points
une organisation de protection de la
nature pour que tous les super héros qui
dorment en chacun d'entre nous puisse
venir pour réaliser leur mission les
simples l'idée non
si ce n'est qu'on a rajouté quelques
ingrédients non on a mis de
l'exploration de la recherche
scientifique
et puis de la transmission aux autres et
aux générations futures en particulier
aller sans plus tarder je vais vous
montrer un des premiers épisodes des
aventures d'odyssée luce on l'a appelée
odyssée us et le yati du lac glacé alors
l'histoire elle se passe dans les alpes
on est parti dans les alpes suisses
italiennes et on a gravi les montagnes
on apportait des centaines de kilos de
matériel avec nous on a trouvé un lac
glacé on a percé la glace et on a plongé
ça c'est de l'exploration et puis après
arrivé au fond on a effectué des
prélèvements sédiments et en os et on a
apporté ses échantillons à l'université
de genève aux scientifiques pour qu'ils
puissent réaliser leur étude
ça c'est de la recherche scientifique
et puis enfin cette étude est parue dans
l'une des revues les plus connues dans
le monde au sujet de l'eau water ça
c'est de la transition
et enfin cette étude couplé à d'autres a
permis de mettre en évidence une
pollution aux micro plastiques dans ces
lacs glaciaires qui est dû au polymère
dont sont faits nos vêtements des fibres
très volatile qui se répandent avec les
vend partout sur la terre et cela a
amené une prise de conscience et on
espère faire bouger les choses pour la
confection de nos vêtements de demain ça
c'est de la protection de la nature
on va changer un petit peu et si vous
voulez bien je vous emmène pour le
deuxième épisode des aventures de 10 et
us on l'a appelée odyssée nice c'est le
champagne explosif elle est bien celle
là comme histoire ça se passe dans le
deuxième ou plutôt dans le plus grand
lac d'europe occidentale le lac léman
on est parti un jour à l'aube avec un
bateau que nous avions loué sous un faux
nom pour ne pas éveiller les soupçons
des autorités sur ce que nous devions
faire on est parti sur un point qu'on
s'était fixés on a plongé à plus de 50
mètres dans le noir et dans le froid
ça c'est de l'exploration et puis après
on est tombé sur ce qu'on cherchait des
caisses et des caisses de munitions avec
des bombes à l'intérieur qui avait été
jeté au lendemain de la seconde guerre
mondiale pour s'en débarrasser les
scientifiques se doutait qu'elle était
là mais il n'avait jusqu'à présent eu
aucune image n'a aucune preuve de leur
présence on leur a donc apporté ça c'est
de la recherche scientifique
puis après on a provoqué une conférence
de presse à genève
afin d'informer nos concitoyens
dépollution en cours et des dangers que
cela représente
c'est de la transmission est maintenant
avec la confédération helvétique nous
travaillons pour effectuer des relevés
bathymétriques c'est à dire une
cartographie des fonds lacustres pour
connaître exactement l'emplacement de
toutes ses munitions il y en a plusieurs
milliers de tonnes et procéder à leur
éradication et neutralisation
ça c'est de la protection de la nature
il était bien cet épisode allez je vous
en mets un troisième un troisième qui se
passe pas très loin d'ici
sur le deuxième plus grand affluent de
la méditerranée par le débit après le
nil le rhône en plein coeur de lyon on a
affrété un bateau mis en place un
équipage
on a mis également sur pied une équipe
de plongeurs et une équipe de bénévoles
à terre et on a décidé d'investiguer en
plein centre de lyon le fond du fleuve
c'est de l' aventure on a pu filmer
photographier des quantités incroyables
de macro déchets en tout genre
et également la faune et la flore qui
essayent de survivre dans ce milieu
devenu hostile et on a remis ces
éléments aux scientifiques qui étudient
la pollution sur le rhône ça c'est de la
recherche
on a réalisé le documentaire qui est
derrière moi et on le diffuse dans les
écoles dans lesquelles nous intervenons
pour sensibiliser les gamins à la
pollution
ça c'est de la transmission et puis
enfin ce jour là on a remonté trois
tonnes 5 de déchets en tout genre
les trottinettes des vélos des machines
à laver des batteries des coffres-forts
vide ça c'est de la protection de la
nature
exploration recherche transmission
protection mais en fait
est ce que ce n'est pas tout simplement
une histoire accéléré de l'humanité que
nous revivons au travers des aventures
de décès us allez je m'explique homo
sapiens est apparu en afrique il y a
trois cent mille ans et puis de là il
s'est répandu sur toute la planète il a
exploré il a réalisé d arc des flèches
confectionner des outils des instruments
il a cherché et puis il a appris à ses
enfants à ses congénères à ceux qu'ils
croisaient comment réaliser par eux
mêmes ce qu'ils venaient d'apprendre il
a transmis et enfin en chassant juste ce
dont ils avaient besoin
comme buffle dans des troupeaux en
maintenant un équilibre pour ce troupeau
en pratiquant une agriculture raisonnée
en laissant les sols se reposer se
régénérer quelque part ils à protéger la
nature
ma question est simple
sommes nous toujours homo sapiens celui
qui sait le sage sommes nous toujours
sapiens
personnellement il y à 46 pouces qui ont
sonné à mon horloge et je regarde à la
fenêtre et je m'interroge c'est où qu'on
a merdé
c'est où qu'on mrd quand j'écoute les
dirigeants des gouvernements qui ont
désormais pour certains mon âge qui ont
regardé les mêmes dessins animés que moi
qu'est ce que j'aimerais qui la réveille
le super héros qui dort on nous parle de
vaccins beaucoup en ce moment 1
il faut le trouver le bon oui bien sûr
bien sûr mais moi je crois je crois
qu'on porte en nous deux anticorps pour
nous préserver de cette maladie et des
autres qui vont arriver et qui sont déjà
là deux anticorps fondamentaux
tenez je tourne je trouve à titre
personnel qu'on a trop d'image d'un
monde pollué ravagé incendiés pourtant
elles sont bien vrais elles sont bien
réelles
c'est factuel mais toutes ces images je
crains qu'elle ne provoque un sentiment
de et à quoi bon au point où on en avait
foutu pour foutu voire même de la colère
et si la colère rend aveugle selon le
dicton le petit prince répond lui on ne
voit bien qu'avec le coeur et je crois
sincèrement que le premier des anticorps
et là c'est l'amour
alors notre bateau est en train de
couler un aussi il coule
oui et on n'a pas de canot de sauvetage
non deux solutions soit on quitte le
navire
soit on écope et on tente de colmater la
brèche et ça c'est le deuxième des
anticorps c'est l'espoir quand on
intervient dans les écoles avec notre
banque de super héros auprès des gamins
on ne cesse de leur répéter les enfants
n'oubliez pas que l'adulte qui est
devant vous est juste un gosse comme
vous un petit peu plus vieux et quand
j'emmène mes filles dehors et que je les
vois regarder le monde avec ce masque
sur le visage
je me demande quid de notre jeunesse
depuis deux ans à peu près une gamine de
18 ans sillonne la planète
elle arpente le monde elles frappent aux
portes
ok parfois maladroitement mais toujours
toujours sincèrement elle est le symbole
d'une jeunesse en manque de super héros
et je crois qu'il est temps maintenant
que nous réveillons toutes et tous le
super héros qui dort en nous seul on va
plus vite
à plusieurs on va plus loin
surtout on n'a qu'une seule vie et je
crois que ce sont là les fondamentaux
qui doivent animer une organisation
environnementale en 2021
on a plein d'idées on a plein d'épisodes
qui sont en train d'être tournée je vous
les montre
[Musique]
le monde est beau n'est ce pas il est
encore beau et il est temps de s'y
mettre pour le sauver alors les super
héros vous embarquez vous venez avec
nous et puis je vais citer ce grand
philosophe du millénaire dernier j'ai
nommé buzz l'éclair dans son oeuvre
magistrale toy story vers l'infini et au
delà je vous remercie pour votre
attention je vous souhaite une très
bonne journée
[Applaudissements]